when you were thinking about what people
like
from where did you get a sense that this
is what people like you you said we sat
down we wrote some stuff down on paper
where is that intuition that seems
fundamental to the success
of
an app like instagram where does that
idea where's that list of three things
come from
exactly
only after having studied machine
learning now for a couple years
i like i have a you have understood
yourself
i've started to make connections like
we can go into this later but
obviously the the um
the connections
between machine learning and the human
brain i think are stretched sometimes
right
at the same time
being able to back prop and being able
to like look at the world try something
yeah figure out how you're wrong how
wrong you are
and then nudge your company in the right
direction
based on how wrong you are
is like a fascinating concept right and
i don't we didn't know we were doing it
at the time but that's basically what we
were doing right
we put it out to call it a hundred
people
and you would look at their data you
would say what are they sharing
what like what resonates what doesn't
resonate we think they're going to
resonate with x but it turns out they
resonate with y
okay shift the company towards y
and it turns out if you do that enough
quickly enough you can get to a solution
that has product market fit most
companies fail
because they sit there and they don't
either their learning rate's too slow
they sit there and they're just they're
adamant that they're right even though
the data is telling them they're not
right
or
they their learning rate's too high and
they wildly chase different ideas and
they never actually set on on one where
where they don't groove right and i
think when we sat down and we wrote out
those three ideas what we were saying is
what are the three possible
whether they're local or global maxima
in our world right
that users are telling us they like
because they're using the product that
way
it was clear people liked the photos
because that was the thing they were
doing
and we just said okay like what if we
just cut out most of the other stuff and
focus on that thing
um and then it happened to be a
multi-billion dollar business and
it's that easy by the way yeah i i guess
so um well nobody ever writes about
neural networks that
miserably failed so this this particular
neural network succeeded this is all the
time right yeah but nobody right default
state is failing yes
um when you said the way people are
using the app
is that the lost function for this
neural network or is it also self-report
like do you ever ask people what they
like or do you have to
track exactly what they're doing not
what they're saying
i once made a thanksgiving dinner okay
and
uh it was for
relatives and i like to cook a lot okay
and i worked really hard on picking the
specific
uh dishes and and and i was really proud
because i had planned it out using a
gantt chart and like it was ready on
time and everything was hot nice like i
don't know if you're a big thanksgiving
guy but like the worst thing about
thanksgiving is when the turkey is cold
and some things are hot and something
anyway you got a gantt chart you
actually have a chart oh yeah yeah omni
plan fairly expensive like gantt chart
thing that i think maybe 10 people have
purchased
in the world but i'm one of them and i
use it for recipe planning only around
big holidays
that's brilliant by the way do people do
this kind of uh over engineering it's
not overdue it's just engineering it's
planning like thanksgiving is a
complicated uh
set of events with some uncertainty with
a lot of things going on you should be
able you should be planning in this way
there should be a chart it's not over i
mean so what's funny is um
brief aside yes uh brilliant i love
cooking i love food i love coffee and
i've spent some time with some chefs who
like know their stuff
and
they always just take out a piece of
paper and just work backwards in rough
order like it's never perfect but rough
order it's just like oh that makes sense
why not just work backwards from from
the end goal right and put in some
buffer time and
so i probably overspecified it a bit
using a gantt chart but the fact that
you can do it it's what professional
kitchens roughly do
they just don't call it a gantt chart or
at least i don't think they do um anyway
i was telling a story about thanksgiving
so here's uh here's the thing
i'm sitting down we have the meal and
then i'm
you know i got to know ray dalio
fairly well over maybe the last year of
instagram um
and one thing that he kept saying was
like feedback is really hard to get
honestly from people
and i sat down at after dinner i said
guys i want feedback what was good and
what was bad yes and what's funny is
like
literally everyone just said everything
was great
and i like personally knew i had screwed
up a handful of things
um but no one would say it
and can you imagine now
not something as high stakes as
thanksgiving dinner okay thanksgiving
dinner it's not that high stakes
but you're trying to build a product and
everyone knows you left your job for it
you're trying to build it out and you're
trying to make something wonderful
and it's yours right you designed it
now try asking for feedback
and know that you're giving this to your
friends and your family
people have trouble giving hard feedback
people have trouble saying
i don't like this or this isn't great or
this is how it's failed me
in fact
um
you usually have two classes of people
people who just won't say bad things you
can literally say to them please tell me
what you hate most about this and they
won't do it they'll try but they won't
and then the other class of people are
just negative period about everything
and it's hard to parse out like what is
true and what isn't
so my rule of thumb with this
is you should always ask people
but at the end of the day it's amazing
what data will tell you
and that's why with whatever project i
work on even now
collecting data from the beginning on
usage patterns so engagement how many
days of the week do they use it
how many i don't know if we were to go
back to instagram how many impressions
per day
right is that growing is that shrinking
and don't be like overly
scientific about it right because maybe
you have 50 beta users or something
but what's fascinating is that
data doesn't lie
people are very
uh defensive about their time
they'll say oh i'm so busy i'm sorry i
didn't get to use the app like i'm just
you know um
but i don't know you're posting on
instagram the whole time
so i don't know at the end of the day
like at facebook there was
you know before time spent became
kind of this loaded
term there
the idea that people
people's currency in their lives is time
and they only have a certain amount of
time to give things whether it's friends
or family or apps or tv shows or
whatever it's
there's no way of inventing more of it
at least not that i know of
if they don't use it it's because it's
not great
so
the moral of the story is you can ask
all you want but you just have to look
at the data
and
data doesn't lie right i mean there's
metrics there's
data can obscure the key insight if
you're not careful so
so time spent in the app that's ones
there's so many metrics you can put at
this and they will give you totally
different insights
especially when you're trying to create
something that doesn't obviously exist
yet
so
you know
measuring maybe
why you left the app or measuring
special moments
of happiness that will make sure you
return to the app or moments of
happiness that are long lasting versus
like dopamine short term
all of those things but i think i
suppose in the beginning
you can just get away with just asking
the question
which features are used a lot let's do
more of that
you